this one comes from John Vera via
Facebook if we were to make contact with
alien life would it be possible for us
to contract diseases from them if so
what our immune systems be able to adapt
to alien diseases seeing as how we've
never encountered them before that is
such a good question can I take a first
pass at that ok sister my aliens okay
unless you like aliens to know here's
here's an interesting point I think okay
um in principle we could catch a disease
from aliens but I think it's highly
unlikely really yes because they'd be
completely different from us
typically this jumping of species from
one it's like there's something similar
sort of from one species to another it
might have a vertebrate you know legs
arms you know a head we don't ever catch
we will never catch Dutch elm disease
okay
and trees don't catch the flu all right
that I know of well whooping cough so
the more remote and Maya correctly from
Aomori the more remote but species is
genetically from you the less likely
they're gonna have a disease that can
jump to you okay now so therefore aliens
would be the maximally remote kind of
life to you because they would have been
almost some other planet with some other
DNA if they had DNA at all Oh glory that
was awesome let's get the either
confirmation or rebuttal from nori or me
start with the wrong part where was I
wrong most well in 1963 when JFK gave me
let's go to the movie speech we get to
one was in 1961 and another was 1962 it
was in a then-record young Nobel
laureate Joshua Lederberg the
um mr. president I think we need to have
a meeting here because if we go to the
room and we take our human microbes as
hitchhikers with us to unavoidable to
the moon and there is any life-form at
all that we don't know about on the moon
our microbes might kill that life-form
and conversely if there's any life form
on the moon we might bring it back with
us his question spawned a very large
effort by NASA to deal with the
possibility of one direction or another
spreading disease which by the way was
picked up by Michael Crichton and became
his famous book Andromeda Strain my
favorite books of the era actually and
there is a lot of theoretical talk that
life was ceded by asteroids carrying
life forms of some point were essential
nucleotide elements so there's that side
the other side however the flip side of
that is sort of right about your answer
is the experience of Australia so as far
as we know the Australian continent had
no placental mammals except Homo sapiens
until the Europeans came and so it was
you know lots and lots of creatures that
carry their babies and pouches and a lot
more soupy a lot of marsupials and the
infectious disease rate from all verbal
records because there are no written
ones of the Aboriginal peoples was very
very low and indeed they were said to
live extremely long lives into their
90's until the Westerners came and then
they were obliterated by one disease
after another the Westerners are similar
are the same species and Switek know
they can catch the same disease right
and they brought with them all sorts of
mammals ah cats and pigs and horses and
so on and all of the stuff that the
continent of Australia never saw before
never saw before that's an excellent
example out there so basically here's
the answer if these aliens are not just
for happening this is the Chuck nice
if these aliens are not traveling with
horses and cows then we're cool we're
fine we're in deep doo-doo if they're in
trouble apparently there's your answer
John
well that was fascinating I don't tell
ya and seeing you to actually go back
and forth with made it even better I'm
all the terror yes so this this concern
with the NASA astronauts led to the
quarantine of the Apollo moon walkers
when they came back you might remember
we were there in like a like a Winnebago
or something exactly yes and there they
are sort of waving through the window
right they were analyzed for possible
infections infectious agents and the
duration of time in there got less and
less for each subsequent and we find out
know the moon is completely possible to
all life so basically just come back